the concept of factorial is very
important in mathematics it's written as
an exclamation mark after the number so
if we have this then we call it 7
factorial but what is its value let's
see suppose we need to find the value of
3 factorial we write it as three times
two times one we go on until we reach
the number one
so the value of three times two times
one is six
so what will be five factorial it'll be
five times four times three times two
times one and we have reached till one
so we shall stop the answer is 120 now
before signing off here are a few
interesting questions for you what is
the value of 1 factorial and what is the
value of 0 factorial and what is the
value of 7 factorial do let us know in
the comments section